we are following a government emergency
team that's been in the village of
contagnos for nearly a week
hundreds of families once lived here but
a major landslide reduced a once
thriving community to rubble
their work has been difficult for days
they have retrieved bodies on the
outskirts of the village and are slowly
digging for more
cantagnos is just one of the many areas
devastated by tropical storm maggie
earlier this week
but the scale of the death and damaged
has shocked many and the province is
still reeling from the effects of
another typhoon four months
ago president rodrigo duterte arrived in
later late on friday he visited
hospitals full of rescued civilians
the smell of decaying bodies is quite
overwhelming
just behind me
is is a neighborhood that rescuers took
several days to access it may seem close
from where we are but they actually had
to go around and secure the perimeter in
order to reach that area now the focus
of responders now
have gone from rescue to retrieval
in the town of bunga marites martinez
lost 16 members of her family it took
several days before their bodies were
retrieved
i still feel as if they're here that
they're still alive
it's quite a shock
molito tablet also lost his daughter and
two
grandchildren
it hurts my chest hurts
i just spoke to them the day before
the martinez family has set up this tent
and just like hundreds of others here
they are in desperate need of aid so
there is no time to grieve
jamel allendogen al-jazeera later
province central philippines